un infierno en la nieve para miles de
emigrantes más de un millar de personas
quedaron desamparadas después de que las
llamas acabarán con el campamento de
refugiados el 23 de diciembre ahora la
nieve empeora su situación
cruise ya en selvin ya croacia y
eslovenia por favor les rogamos que nos
den una oportunidad de ir hacia italia
wang ywen chance en bosnia la vida es
peligrosa
todos estos inmigrantes están en una
situación realmente mala en bosnia
si las autoridades planeaban relocalizar
a los migrantes en el municipio de veras
dina a 320 kilómetros mientras se
formaban las instalaciones pero el
acuerdo nunca llegó y tuvieron que
quedarse esperando en la fría intemperie
la policía bosnia cree que fueron
algunos migrantes quienes incendiaron el
campamento como forma de protesta por
las condiciones del mismo y por la
retirada de la organización
internacional para las migraciones
ahora mi casa está quemada este
campamento es mi casa todos los
alojamientos están quemados no tenemos
en ningún tipo de instalación
yo estoy durmiendo en los baños muchas
personas tienen enfermedades y no hay ni
medicinas ni doctores y hospitales
scripting en sant
según fuentes oficiales la remodelación
de la infraestructura elipa comenzará
aunque no será hasta abril se estima que
unos 10.000 migrantes de asia oriente
medio y el norte de áfrica han quedado
atrapados en bosnia camino de países
europeos más ricos